it says Nick has five different pairs of
socks to last the working week good for
him they're scattered loose in his
drawer because
um I don't know he's messy and
disorganized good for him each morning
he gets up before light and chooses two
socks at random find the probability
that okay so here's my question to you
first
um was it one of those cases where you
had some answers and you're like doesn't
match or were you like I don't even know
where to begin with a question life is
yeah that's okay so what I'm going to do
is
um even though it's like oh you know
we're in we're in year 11 and 12 right
we should be Beyond this right I
actually think it is enormously helpful
in concrete questions like this like
socks right I mean I didn't bring socks
with me but to actually see what's going
on and I promise actually the numbers
will become a lot easier to think about
once you actually have these right so
here are my because I don't have socks I
use Domino's but here are my five pairs
okay and they all they all match right
so he picks at random let's just take it
one question at a time so it says find
the probability that he wears a matching
pair on the first morning okay all right
so here's us we're Nick right we come to
the drawer it obviously doesn't look
this neat I mean even if it did look
that neat I'm not looking it's dark
right so I pick a sock at random for my
first sock and I'm going to pick two
socks this morning right
for the first sock
does it matter which color I choose
it doesn't because it doesn't say like
on the first morning does he have a
matching pair that's red it's just any
of the pairs would be fine as long as it
matches right so let's suppose we by
chance we pick up a green song okay so
this one is in Nick's hand at the moment
okay so now remember we it didn't have
to be the green one it could have been
any of the other ones it's fine so I
could have picked any of the 10 for this
so in some ways the probability of
choosing this is actually 10 out of 10.
because you're like any of them is fine
any of them is a favorable outcome right
but then I've got to work out the second
sock right now I want to know firstly
how many options are left because that's
the sample space and you can see it
there are nine options left
how many of them are the one that will
create a matching pair and it's like
there's only one that satisfies that so
in order to get that in there the only
favorable outcome left is one out of
nine
and that's the answer right one times
one out of nine so that's all there is
to it okay now what you really need to
start thinking about this is if you have
a look at B and C
they feel like different questions yeah
what's the probability on the last
morning what's it probably on the third
morning okay now if you have a look at
all those earlier questions that you
were doing and even questions like this
right they lean you in the direction and
this is part of a part of the trick a
little bit they lean you in the
direction of thinking okay if you want
to know what's happening on the last
morning you've got to know what happened
on all the previous mornings right
except that's kind of they're actually
trying to fool you a little bit because
I want you to imagine this right it says
let's do the part B what's the
probability that he wears a matching
pair on the last morning
do I care what happens
on warning one two three and four
I mean according to this question
they're unimportant right so that means
that in much the same way as for the
very first sock on the first morning
like I don't care which sock that you
picked right
um all of those probabilities they're
just going to multiply by 10 over 10 or
9 over 9 or 8 over 8. they don't change
your probability at all because they're
just equal to one right so another way
you can think about this and I don't
know if you stuck a look at the answer
right but what you can do is you can say
well you know how I said oh let's make
this your first morning's socks right
there's no reason why I can't say
for some reason Nick decided to go and
actually pick out all his socks for the
whole week
on that first morning and he decided you
know what this is going to be the last
morning's pair of socks and he picked it
out and this is what happened these were
the probabilities
so just because it's the first morning
or the second morning or the third
morning if I don't care what happens for
the other mornings this is the same
probability for him getting a matching
pair on the last morning
and it's the same probability for him
getting a matching pair on the third
morning because imagine you and I walked
in and we saw Nick pick out a pair of
socks and we said hey don't wear that
today wear it on Wednesday it's like
okay whatever the problem the numbers
haven't changed have they like the socks
haven't changed all calculations are
identical so actually this is your
answer for part A and for Part B and for
part C that's it one over nine they're
all the same okay yeah
all right part D though this is where
things do change right so this is the
probability of matching socks
um for one morning
yep
equals that okay so now when I think
about matching socks for two mornings
now can you see when I come back on
Tuesday or Wednesday or whichever day
right I actually do care what happened
the previous morning I need both of them
to be true so the way that I would
actually write this out in my working
years it's the probability of it's lunch
one right cool it's the probability of
one morning
and then I'm going to use some of the
notation that would use in the other
question if we if we get to it right I
need to multiply by the probability of
the second morning
and then have you seen this vertical bar
before in some of those do you know what
it means do you know what the in because
I can tell you if you
yeah yeah yeah yeah so sometimes you'll
see this right you'll see this notation
what it means is what's the probability
of a occurring if you know that B has
occurred right so for example I could
say to you
um it's a it's a wet miserable day today
right and I can say what's the
probability of rain today right well the
probability of rain if I pick a random
day in the year is different to if I say
what's the probability of like um my
family's from Malaysia right and there's
a monsoon season right now during
monsoon season if I told you
um Doris it's monsoon season right now
what do you think is the chance it's
gonna be raining you'd be like it's 100
because it's monsoon season it just
rains non-stop every day for weeks right
so that is the probability of rain
given that I know it's monsoon season is
different to just the probability of
rain because there's times when it
doesn't rain right so in this case I
want to say what's the probability that
I get the matching pair again if I know
that I got it on the first morning
and then I have to multiply those two
together because I want them both to
happen I want the first morning and I
want the second morning okay now we
actually already know the first morning
it's one out of nine that's what we just
worked out okay now I have to work out
what happens the next day okay
so here's the situation the next day I
know it looks like this because on the
first morning I took out two identical
socks right so now I'm going to pick out
I guess you could say it's sock number
three yeah does it matter which one of
these socks I pick
no it doesn't there are eight to choose
from suppose I picked the blue one right
so here it is right now because like you
said it doesn't matter which one this is
eight out of eight right eight
possibilities but you could pick any of
them that's fine right
but now I want it to match so you have a
look how many socks are left
well you've actually answered both
questions right one of them is the
favorable outcome and there are seven
left over there right only one of them
is the
blue one yeah so then the probability is
a ninth times one
times a seventh it's just the nine and
the Seven it's one out of 63.
that's it
do you see how I worked through that
yeah
okay
now
um I wonder if you're seeing for part e
what the pattern is right so this is
like first morning
this is I'm just going to highlight here
right because this eight over eight
doesn't really matter it's first morning
second morning right what would you
guess happens on the third morning
yeah and it's one out of five because
you know here we are starting the third
morning right and you're like oh I don't
care it's six out of six so you pick the
red one and then there's five left and
one of them's a good one right so if I
wanted to say where is my working Gonna
Go part e over here right the
probability is going to be in the first
instance there's the first morning
there is the second one which we just
did right here comes the third one and
then what would you guess the third
morning is yeah
now on the last morning presuming it's
actually worked right so every morning I
have successfully gotten the matching
pair right Nick wakes up
he's already done four days where it's
all matched so what's gonna happen
what's the probability that he gets a
match on the last day
it's just one so therefore
that's my whole answer whatever that
happens to be okay and that partly
answers the last question Part F
find the probability that he wears a
matching pair every morning but one
so every morning he gets a matching pair
but on the last morning he doesn't now
just think about this for a second right
there's day one day two day three day
four and now I've gotten them matching
every morning and then here are the
final socks that I have left is it
possible for me to not have a matching
pair on the last day
and the answer is no because the only
socks that are left
match with each other right so my answer
to Part F would be uh it's impossible
the probability is zero does that make
sense